التفسير حتى اللحظة. بدأت
السلطات في تشيلي التحقيق في
الانتهاكات المتواصلة في حق
الايجور. قرية تركية تشكو سماع
انهاء الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا.
قال زعيم التيار الصدري العراقي
اجراء محادثات مباشرة مع نظيره
الصيني وذلك من اجل المساعدة في
اوكرانية. اسرائيل قدوتنا. زوجة
زالنسكي تتضامن مع الاسرائيليين
اما بوتين مستمر في مضاعفة
معاناة اوروبا. فلمن ستكون
العفوية. وطالب الصدر المعتصمين
بالبقاء والاستمرار في اعتصامهم
الجيران العرب. كشفت تقارير عن
مساع للرئيس الاوكراني من اجل
السفارات في كندا وامريكا وتركيا
وبريطانيا وجنوب افريقيا بوقف
العملية. واظهرت مقاطع فيديو
نشرت منصات وحسابات اسرائيلية
تل ابيب عقب حادثة اطلاق نار على
خلفية جنائية ظنا بانهما منفذا
واشنطن دعمها للاحتجاجات السلمية
ولدعوة رئيس الوزراء العراقي
مؤسسات داعمة لحقوق الانسان
مظاهرات عالمية تدعم الايجور
المسلمين الذين تعرضوا لابادة
الصين ومجازرها وسط مطالبات امام
اصوات مرعبة قادمة من تحت الارض
تتبعها هزات ارضية تعجز عن
شمالي البلاد. الصين تثبت جديتها
باطلاق صواريخها الباليستية
ورفع الاحداثيات. هنا يصرح وزير
الدفاع الروسي قائلا لقد دمرنا
الاوكراني والقتال في دومبس اشبه
بالجحيم. قتال وحشي ومعارك دامية
تنظيم القاعدة الارهابي. اذ ان
امريكا لن تتوقف عن وريث جديد
ضد العرب قائلة ان تل ابيب تواجه
نفس ظروف الحرب في بلادها لكن مع
تستعد لها القوات الاوكرانية دام
الثمن هو عادة خرسون. الاحداث
تحالف اوبك بلس عن زيادة في
انتاجها من النفط الخام تصل الى
والتطورات. اسرائيل تبصق على
الامارات وتهين اماراتيين في قلب
وتحمل امريكا المسئولية في
منزلنسكي يتقرب من بكين من موسكو
ونصف المليون جنيه استرليني
وعشرة ملايين دولار لمن يدلي
مقتدى الصدر ان الشعب العراقي
سئم الطبقة الحاكمة. وانه لا
بمعلومات عنه، ويوصف سيف العدل
بانه احد اكثر عناصر القاعدة
مصطفى الكاظمي للعودة للحوار.
اعلنت الدول المنتجة للنفط في
تل ابيب اذ اعتقلت الشرطة
الاسرائيلية شخصين اماراتيين في
المصانع الالمانية ما سيؤثر
وبشكل كبير على الاقتصاد
لحين تحقيق المطالب. واشار الصدر
في الى ان الاصلاح لا ياتي الا
لقيادة التنظيم تمتز به الدول
الغنية بالنفط اذا من هو وريث
فاعلية من القادة الاحياء من
حقبة ما قبل هجمات الحادي عشر من
بالتضحية وانه على استعداد تام
للشهادة في الوقت ذاته اعلنت
مائة الف برميل يوميا في شهر
سبتمبر ايلول القادم. نظمت
لحظة القبض على بين الاماراتيين
واعتقالهما بطريقة مهينة. مقتل
عمقها مائتي متر ظهرت خلال عطلة
نهاية الاسبوع في منطقة منجم
حفرة غامضة يبلغ قطرها حوالي
خمسة وعشرين مترا فيما يبلغ
ان امريكا تدعم اوكرانيا بسلاح
بشريطة الدفاع عن النفس دون ان
امريكا مسؤولية اي قصف صاروخي قد
يطال الاراضي الروسية ولا ننسى
يكون بوتين قد خنق الالماني
لقنهم درسا في فرض العقوبات. لكن
حتى يصل لدرجة الهجوم على روسيا?
وهنا يحمل وزير الدفاع الروسي
العسكرية الاخيرة في منطقة الفيف
الاوكرانية. وهي المنطقة
وثمانين وكان انضمامه للقاعدة
مكسبا لها بسبب تمتعه بقدرات
المحاذية لبولندا. برأيكم هل
سيمتد الدعم الامريكي لاوكرانيا
المطارات المحلية التي تعد
اوكرانيا. ومن ثم نشرها وتوزيعها
عالية الدقة مستودعا لتخزين
الاسلحة الاوكرانية من المساعدات
الظواهري اليوم يظهر اسم جديد
ستسمعونه كثيرا من الان وصاعدا
فائدة ترجى من الحوار خصوصا بعد
ان قال الشعب كلمته الحرة
سبتمبر الذين يمكنهم تولي زمام
امور التنظيم. جواسيس بوتين. من
تدخل اوكرانيا وتعيق التقدم
الروسي. ولهذا يضطر الجيش الروسي
يبدو انه سيعود قريبا للعمل.
متحدث الكرملين قال ان انخفاض
للاستعانة بجيش الظل او اصحاب
القبعات السوداء. نعم الروس حيث
في اكثر من نقطة بعدها تسرب
مواعيد الرحلات من قبل بعض
قائلة اذا واصلت الولايات
المتحدة السلوك في المسار الخاطئ
محافظة المنوفية في مصر انضم سيف
العدل الى التنظيم عام تسعة
مهلا الم يفرض الغربيون الاف
العقوبات على روسيا متحدين الدب
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي تحظر
روسيا الغاز على اكبر مدن
بوتين يخنق المانيا. من يعاقب
من? سؤال اثار غضب الالمان في
المرافق العامة وقطع الماء
الساخن على الحمامات واحواض
السباحة. المانيا وروسيا ما
زالتا تتبادلان الاتهامات حول
امدادات الغاز الى المانيا تسببت
بها عقوبات بولندا ووقف اوكرانيا
الصاروخية الامريكية هايبرز لم
تحدث اي فارق لصالح الجيش
اسباب ازمة الطاقة التي بدأت بعد
ازالة روسيا توربينا من خط ولا
امدادات الطاقة من موسكو منها
تخفيض استهلاك الاضاءة في
متابعتنا. وتضيف وزارة الخارجية
الصينية هذا التصريح الناري
زعيم القاعدة ايمن الظواهري
بغارة امريكية لا يعني انتهاء
وخبرة عسكرية لا تقدر بثمن. في
عام ثمانية وتسعين. رصدت وكالة
يغرقوا في الظلام. يا لهذه
السخرية. وريث الظواهري. مقتل
المانيا هانوفر التي اعلنت
اجراءات استثنائية لمقاومة نقص
محمد صلاح الدين زيدان المعروف
باسم سيف العدل المصري من مواليد
المخابرات الامريكية والبريطانية
مكافآت مالية بمقدار سبعة ملايين
الالماني الذي قد يخفض انتاج
المصانع الى اقل من النصف. وبهذا
ستة عشر شخصا في هجمات صاروخية
على اكثر من ثلاثين بلدة
العالم بحصة قد تصل الى تسعين
بالمئة ما يعني انها قد تتسبب
والاجهزة الالكترونية بانواعها.
لذا حافظوا على هواتفكم تتمكن من
يصل اي منها الى الاراضي الروسية
وهنا يصرح زالانسكي. الانظمة
فستتحمل المسئولية. وعندها لا
يمكنها القول ان احدا لم يحذرها.
اكثر الكوابيس التي تؤرق روسيا
هي شحنات الاسلحة الغربية التي
تصل الاسلحة والدعم الغربي الى
بولندا ويتم توزيعها عن طريق
الافراد الذين يعملون في هذه
المطارات حتى يتم تحديد الاهداف
تستخدم في صناعة الرقائق
الالكترونية حيث ان تايوان تشارك
عن مصدر تايواني ان طائرات وقطعا
بحرية صينية اخترقت لوقت قصير
الروسي واليوم ها هم يترجونه ان
لا يقطع عنهم الغاز حتى لا
سنعاقب كل من يسيء الى بلاد في
اشارة لزيارة نانسي بيلوسي الى
تايوان. نعم ضربات دقيقة تم
ضربها في مساحات واسعة قرب مضيق
تايوان ليعلن بعدها مجلس العموم
البريطاني نيته زيارة تايوان. يا
رئيسي اقتصادي مع تايوان وهو
ايقاف تصدير الرمال الصينية التي
الخط الاوسط قرب مضيق تايوان.
ولم تكتف بذلك بل قامت بقطع
لاحد الخطوط انخفاض امدادات
الطاقة يعني توقف الكثير من
بتوقف مصانع التكنولوجيا كصناعة
الهواتف النقالة والكمبيوترات
تايوان ضمن تدريبات عسكرية مخطط
لها مسبقا. وكانت رويترز قد نقلت
تعلم ماذا صنعت الصين اليوم؟ لقد
بصواريخها الباليستية تجاه
دبلوماسي هزيل وهذا ما حدث. عذرا
ماذا تقول رد دبلوماسي هزيل؟ الم
الهوليودية وكيف انطوت على الصين
هنا يقف الجيش الصيني في حيرة من
نهاية المعركة قرية تركية تشكو
من اصوات مرعبة قادمة من تحت
الى اليابان اولا. وهنا تدخل
نانسي بيلوسي بطائرة عادية تابعة
مهلا الى الوراء قليلا. الم تعلن
الصين سيطرتها على الاجواء في
بكين ويصف بريطانيا انها ترقص
على نفس الاوتار التي رقصت عليها
الاستخبارات الامريكية التي صرحت
ان طائرة امريكية عسكرية مرت
امره. اذ اصبحوا تحت مقصلة اشعال
الحرب لاستعادة سيادتها او رد
للولايات الامريكية وتهبط على
جزيرة تايوان. يا لهذه الحبكة
بجوار جزيرة تايوان وحسب
البروتوكولات الرسمية انها ستذهب
للعجب! ماذا يريد الجميع من
تايوان ليأتي الرد الصيني من
الارض فما الذي يحدث? دخان
الحرب. وزير الخارجية الصيني
ومقتدى الصدر يعلنها للعلن
لتتدخل واشنطن فمن سيغلب من في
جزيرة تايوان. اذا كيف دخلت
نانسي بيلوسي هنا يأتي الرد من
اما بوتين فهو مستمر في خنق
الاقتصاد الاوروبي وجيوش الظلام
التي اطلقتها الصين على مضيق
تايوان. الصين تثبت جديتها وتحمل
الغلبة بعد هذا كله?
تنتشر في حدود بولندا. الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يبصق في وجه الامارات
امريكا وانها لن تتساهل في الامر
وان هناك ردا صينيا قادما. ولكن
رائحة الباروت تملأ المكان. نعم
انها رائحة الصواريخ الباليستية
امريكا المسؤولية فيما زالنسكي
يتقرب من بكين لتغيثه من موسكو.